[Music]
we want to share
a rare story this morning about a woman
who got a stunning surprise
after the fight of her life it begins
with a bad break and a frightening
diagnosis
chip reed has more when doris krippen
broke her arm in may
i laid that for 24 hours before i was
found
and i thought i was going to die the
diagnosis was even more devastating
she had covid19 a risky proposition for
someone who's 73.
hoping it's something i never want to
ever get again
but the bitter pill became easier to
swallow when doris met her medication
aid
bev boro at this rehab center outside
omaha nebraska when you
first saw her what went through your
heart and your mind
i just couldn't believe that she was
actually here it's like oh my god
i think this is my sister crippen
doesn't hear very well so boro
picked up a whiteboard and then i showed
it to her and it says
is your father wendell huffman and you
have showed that to her
and doris what was your reaction when
you saw that
my mind's racing i'm thinking why is she
asking me this question
for i don't know her at first
but she did look kind of familiar
familiar it turns out
from 53 years ago the last time i've
seen deadlies
when i rocked her in my arms that she's
too big today to do that
their father was a trucker he would have
my mother go out on the road with him
and left us with a 10 and 11 year old to
take care of
six months to five years old so the
neighbor called the state
borough just six months old at the time
was sent to foster care
crippen who was 20 and living elsewhere
tried to locate her
i've been searching for my sisters for
over 53 years but i knew they were out
here but i just never could find them
now they're finding new family through
each other so far i'm really bonding
with my assistant so you see each other
a lot now
yes it's hard on these residents and
patients when you can't have a visitor
and with her i see her like three or
four times a day
would it be fair to say there have been
a lot of tears since you two got
reunited oh yes and now a new chapter
in this sister act i can't wait to when
i can get out and if i can go spend some
time with her
and meet her husband and meet our
children oh it's going to be amazing
i guess it was god's plan that this
happened because if i didn't have the
cover i would have never found my sister
for cbs this morning i'm chip reed
what a reunion vlad what a reunion i
love it when she said she looked kind of
familiar
through this adversity through this
horrible pandemic what a beautiful story
chip read
i loved it i had my mouth open the
entire time yeah and the pictures of the
two of them together are really great